dans cette école maternelle du quartier
de planoise à besançon les trois
enseignantes feront grève jeudi la
réforme des retraites qui prévoit un
seul et même mode de calcul pour le
public comme le privé désavantagera
considérablement les professeurs des
écoles le calcul du du montant de la
pension sur les six derniers mois de
salaire était une façon de compenser un
petit peu la faiblesse du salaire en
début de carrière disons qu'on est on
avait un faible salaire mais au moment
de la retraite on avait une retraite qui
correspondait davantage à ce qu'on avait
touché en fin de carrière là en prenant
en compte l'ensemble de la rémunération
de la carrière donc dont le début est
très très faible
les enseignants se trouve largement
pénalisés de l'école primaire au lycée
cette remise en cause des pensions
exacerbe le ras-le-bol de nombreux
enseignants qui se plaignent déjà des
réformes répétées des programmes d'un
manque de considération générale et
d'une trop faible rémunération
nous avons fait un simulateur de calcul
de retraite hey il apparaît que les
pertes sont de 300 jusqu'à 1000 euros
par mois par futurs retraités c'est
absolument énorme pour nous c'est pas
acceptable et du coup vous attendez une
forte mobilisation des enseignants
la mobilisation sera sans doute massive
et ça vient également du fait que les
enseignants sont mécontents de la
faiblesse de leurs salaires de leurs
mauvaises conditions de travail et du
mépris affiché du ministre blanc caire
qui n'écoutent jamais ce que nous avons
à dire dans le seul département du doubs
une centaine d'écoles primaires seront
complètement fermées jeudi notamment
l'établissement le plus important du
département l'école fourier et ses 27
classes à besançon pour les enseignants
du premier degré le préavis de grève est
valable jusqu'au mardi 10 décembre